[Applause]
the three of us have all had the
privilege of bringing a beloved animated
character to the live screen i played
cinderella naomi was princess jasmine
and soon hallie will join the club as
ariel in the little mermaid welcome babe
thank you girls
thank you
all these characters hold such a special
place in our hearts because animated
films make up some of our most formative
movie experiences as kids so many kids
watch these movies over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
i see some parents out there know
exactly what we're talking about
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film
encanto
jared busch byron howard yvette mourinho
and clark spencer
[Applause]
flee
jonas rasmussen monica hellstring cena
bureau saranson and charlotte delegonado
luca enrico casarosa and andrea warren
the mitchells versus the machines mike
rienda phil lord christopher miller and
kurt albrecht
ryan and the last dragon don hall
carlos lopez estrada osnature and peter
delveco
[Music]
[Applause]
and the oscar goes to
this is the first oscar and nomination
for jared bush and yvette mourinho the
second win and third nomination for
byron howard and clark spencer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness um
hi
uh thank you to the academy thank you it
is i am so proud to be a part of a film
that puts beautiful diverse characters
in front and center
and that people everywhere are seeing
themselves in the film
we have some key people to thank our
encounter music department led by the
incomparable lin-manuel miranda
and jermaine franco and our superhero
that are our strength charis castro
smith our co-director the heart of the
madrigal family and everyone at the walt
disney animation studios this film only
exists because of your talent and your
passion jennifer lee and alan bergman
for championing this film from the very
beginning and we have to thank the
entire country of colombia our amazing
cast
this is a movie about family and we
would not be here without our family
someone with dake my wife pam my kids
merrick emmitt and hewitt my parents
gone and adrian uh shepard my husband my
family on both coasts my dad i miss you
and my husband raphael and felix and
noemie
[Applause]
[Music]
you